what's going on guys today I'm going to
explain every founding Titan in the
history of Attack on Titan at its full
potential this shifter is pretty much
Invincible as it has control over every
subject of your mirror not to mention
all Titans and Titan shifters for 100
years his powers were severely weakened
due to the baronizing war but luckily
for Aaron that battle only affects
people who have Royal Blood as a result
he can use its true abilities when the
right conditions are met which is unlike
most of his recent predecessors by my
account there are 10 characters who have
used the Founder's power that we know of
and in this video I'll be going through
the details of each one in the process
we'll discuss the different ways they've
used it and where the power of the
Titans even comes from but spoiler
winning ahead for the second half of the
final season if you're interested in
more content like this then do check out
my Attack on Titan playlist since I've
not done a video on all of the night
shifters
okay so the first person on this list is
yamir Fritz who was the original
founding Titan from nearly 2 000 years
ago for a long time it was speculated
that her abilities came from some kind
of deal with the devil but I would argue
the truth is even more bizarre in the
beginning Emir was a powerless child
from a random Village however one day
her people were attacked by a tribe
known as the eldians this tribe was led
by a man called Carl Fritz and they
proceeded to kill him as parents cut out
her tongue and capture her as a slave
for good measure soon afterwards she was
made to perform various tasks for the
eldians alongside the other slaves and
this included things like transporting
jugs of water and looking after the pigs
on one fateful day she intentionally
left the gate of the pigpen open
allowing wanted the pigs to escape and
this decision although it seemed
harmless at first unfortunately that
choice would lead to billions and
billions of deaths by letting the animal
go she was almost immediately blamed for
it and alien soldiers were sent by Fritz
to chase her through the forest even
though the situation seemed hopeless a
wounded yamir continued to stumble
forward to survive and this is where we
come to the origin of the Titans in
chapter 137 Zeke gave almond a lesson
about how life on Earth began and during
that monologue we saw these organisms in
the sea the one on the left made a brief
appearance during the season 2 opening
but the creature in the center is the
real one we need to talk about this type
of worm is referred to as hallucigenia
which is an extinct species that existed
hundreds of millions of years ago in the
real world in the attack on Titan
Universe though a large mutated version
of this creature existed during emir's
Lifetime and had the power to Lodge on
other things within the ldm forest there
was a massive tree that stood high above
all others and its size was likely
caused by the hallucinogenia living
underneath it of course Emir herself had
no reason to suspect anything so she
walked into this tree thinking she'd
have a place to hide but soon fell down
into the water below as she desperately
struggled for breath the mutant worm
quickly approached her and fused itself
into her spine this merging of human and
husaginia is what led to the creation of
the first founding Titan with her
Invincible body towering over everything
in sights in terms of her Design This
original Titan had distinctive features
that we don't often see like her
protruding ribs and the fact her skull
has no flesh whatsoever while there is
no official confirmation on her size I'd
estimate that she's at least taller than
the Colossal although let me know in the
comments what you think her exact height
might be now despite her Newfound power
you may return to Surf Club Fritz in
what was a strange town of events you'd
assume she'd want revenge for him
enslaving her and destroying her
hometown but instead she went on to obey
him as a Titan for the following 13
years her Titan body also helped to
build roads Bridges and anything useful
to ld's expansion but importantly she
didn't have access to the coordinates
full abilities this will become clearer
as the video goes on but most of the
Founder's powers only work on subjects
of yamir who are the people descended
from Emir herself regular human beings
are totally unaffected by things like
memory manipulation for example so at
this point in history she couldn't use
his true potential regardless of that
the alien Empire was still able to
expand at a ridiculously fast rate and
King Fritz became a very powerful
individual you may would go on to have
three of his children over the years
with their names being Mario rose and
Sheena which may sound familiar because
the wolves and parodies were named after
them on the day their mother died the
King was addressing his soldiers in the
military when one of them Rose up and
straight up tried to assassinate him he
threw a spirit Fritz with pinpoint
accuracy but you made herself jumped in
the way and took the Fatal blow while
this was a serious injury it's
conceivable that a Titan shifter should
be able to survive this as long as they
have the will to live it's probable that
Yumi is will to live vanish when she
looked up at King Fritz as the two of
them made direct eye contact after she
was attacked in that moment her
daughters were crying but the king
himself showed no emotion despite the
fact she just saved his life he simply
told her to stand up and get back to
work and only when she heard this did
her eyes begin to close her soul was
reborn in what we now know to be the
past Dimension and from there she would
have probably the worst job of all time
in all the times people have been using
the Titans it was Yumi who was creating
those Titan bodies out of sand and then
sending the Flesh and Bones to that
person through Parts in the Final
Chapter arming questioned why you may
would continue to obey Fritz and do all
these things for 2000 years with Aaron
confirming it was because she loved him
clearly we know the king did not love
her back but in dying she still followed
his final order to work because she felt
connected to the world she left behind
before we move on to the next founding
Titan we should probably mention the
curse of Emir which is something that
affects all Titan Shifters since she
died 13 years after getting her Titan
none of her descendants are able to
surpass the length of time with their
bodies deteriorating when the time gets
closer admittedly this affects different
people in different ways as Christian
looked pretty normal when his time was
about to run out whereas URI rice was in
his 30s looking like he was about to
drop dead it's unclear why exactly the
curse of your mirror exists I mean does
he may intentionally make that happen or
is it the will of the coordinate I mean
we just don't know but either way it's
an unavoidable thing that every shifter
goes through with that said the second
founding Titan we know about is one of
emir's daughters and I'm going to
explain how this led to the creation of
the present-day Royal bloodline after
yamir's death Fritz was desperate for
the Titans not to disappear so he forced
his daughters to read every last piece
of our body this is similar to how
people in the present will turn into
pure Titans before eating a shifter but
the main thing they have in common is
that you need to eat the spine the spine
is of course where the hallucinogenia
first connected to yamir so by Mario
rosenshina eating it the Titan powers
are split between them two of them would
have inherited hybrid Titans that are a
mix of the eight shifters we know today
but only one child would have inherited
the true founding Titan as Gabby said
this ancient worm is the coordinate so
it lived on his side whichever sister
had the founder while the other two
shifters were simply connected to it
this ties into the topic of the Royal
bloodline which has always been one of
the more convoluted aspects of this
series by now we should know that only
those with royal blood can activate the
Founder's true potential by themselves
whereas for normies like Aaron there are
more steps involved the problem with
this is that if you go all the way back
every subject of Emir derives from these
two common ancestors meaning that you
know whichever alien you're looking at
they all have Bridges blood inside
though no matter how small it may be why
is it them that aliens like zika
considered to be royalty whereas
everyone else doesn't get those same
benefits one line of thinking is that
maybe not all of the daughters were
Fritz's children although I personally
doubt that theory because I mean he
really thought they were his daughters
and it's inconceivable that yamir would
cheat therefore my own Theory as to why
certain characters have Royal Blood can
be traced back to this moment in the
past Dimension here we see the
coordinate in the center and out of it
are three separate paths each one
representing Mario rosenshina
respectively although all three of them
technically have Royal Blood like I said
earlier only one of these daughters
inherited the Founder's power and
carried on the fritz family name purely
for example if we assume that Mario is
the sister that had the founding Titan
her children and her children's children
would be the ones that you may consider
to be royal blooded since that offshore
of the family would repeatedly go to
parse and tell her what to do it was
individuals from their specific branch
of the family that gave him your orders
for the next two thousand years and this
lineage continued all the way up until
Historia and Zeke no matter how many
subjects of yumeira there might be it
all still traces back to these three
branches so I feel like this could
explain the difference between who yumia
does and doesn't choose to obey I
suspect that when an alien like Grisha
has a baby with a royal that child is
added to Mario's branch of the tree but
in any other scenario where Charles born
to the Rose or Sheena path instead
anyway the third founding title in this
video was an Aldean King from 600 years
before the present day of the series
Sava spoke about this King in season 4
and how he used the coordinate to alter
the bodies of every subject of Emir at
the time the world was being ravaged by
a deadly disease but overnight the king
redesigned the bodies of millions of
aliens so that they were all totally
immune this body modification is one of
the founders most wide-ranging abilities
and unsurprisingly it has also been used
to create pure Titans throughout history
Zeke's power to make pure Titans himself
is a lesser version of that same ability
since his scream only works on those
who've ingested a spinal fluids the
fourth founder we know is Carl Fritz who
is the 145th King of the alien Empire
and the one who ruined everything don't
get me wrong by now the aliens have been
a menace to the world for a long time
but Carl's solution to this problem was
less than ideal I mean just ask anyone
who died in the first three seasons
during willitabi's big production he got
an actor to play the role of Fritz and
this speech gave us an insight into the
former King's mentality Carl was a guy
who felt immense guilt for the sins of
the LDN race since for years they've
been forcibly spreading the butt of your
mirror across the globe and then using
Titans to wipe out entire groups of
people he felt immense sympathy for
Molly in particular and believed that
nothing Elia could do could atone for
the lives they've destroyed to add to
all of this the great Titan war was also
raging on during Carr's lifetime in
which the noble families of Elia had a
civil war using the other eight Titan
Shifters this was essentially the final
straw for him as the infighting made him
realize that the Titan Powers especially
the founder must be kept out of human
hands his solution to all of this began
when he inherited the coordinate himself
as he conspired to take down the alien
Empire there were many different stages
to Fritz his plan but it started when he
guaranteed the type of family's safety
in exchange for them helping Mali to
Take Back Control together they made up
a fake Malian hero named helos who would
go on to be known as the one who
defeated earlier with the help of the
tibers The Story Goes that hellos
manipulated different noble families
into killing each other and has somehow
forced Fritz to retreat to parodies
Island in reality the king wanted to
flee to the island and he brought with
him as many aliens as he could not to
mention many non-subjects of vimea such
as the Asian Clan and also those who
would later be known as Nobles it goes
without saying that he would still leave
many of his people behind on the
continent as well as members of the
royal family who were later be whittled
down to just Zeke in the king's absence
the early Empire continued to crumble
and the Thai was assisted Mali in
stealing seven of the night shifters for
itself with the attack Titan being the
only one to evade capture back on the
island itself Frisk wanted to create a
peaceful Society free of war and he used
the founders power to try and make that
a reality his first action was to
materialize tens of millions of Colossus
Titans which I imagine took him here
quite a long time in paths when those
Titans were in position Carl utilized
their hardening ability to erect the
three Wars we know today and their names
were of course Mario rosenshina Within
These Wars is where his new Society
would be made to live but in true Thanos
style the king didn't think it could be
paradise if people still remembered what
existed before that's why he transformed
into his funny Titan and erased the
memories of nearly all people on the
island he made them believe they were
the last survivors of the human race and
that these wars were constructed to
protect them from the Titans on the flip
side though the ackermans were among a
select group of families unaffected by
the king's memory manipulation their
knowledge of the outside world was a
threat to the paradise that Carl was
trying to create so he offered them
Noble status and privilege to guarantee
their silence while some Bloodlines
accepted this offer the ackermans and
Asians rejected it as they disagreed
with the king's ideology the king did
not take this world as you can
understand and to preserve his
definition of Peace Carl had them hunted
down through the generations until there
were virtually none left hence why there
is only one half asian and a handful of
ackermans in the present day now in an
act of self-protection the Kingdom
changed the Royal Family's name from
Fritz to rice and then he had a random
Noble family take on the fritz name
instead the new Fritz family would
pretend to be the monarchs for the next
100 years but in reality it would be the
Rises who were really in charge behind
the scenes sometime after this Carl used
his abilities again to create the rice
Chapel which is where the Royals pass on
the coordinate for Generations at least
until Grisha rudely interrupted them
overall the king's mindset was their
these past crimes could never be
forgiven and that he would accept it if
Marley one day came to destroy the
island his dream was to live in a
peaceful Society until that day comes
and by making a vow to renounce War
future fighting Titans were possessed by
that same ideology last thing to mention
on Carl is that he made a threat to the
world that he would activate the
rumbling if they tried to attack however
as Willy Tiber revealed that was just a
empty threat and he only set it to
prolong the peace on parodies
fast forward many decades later and the
next founder we saw was an unnamed man
from the royal family he was the father
to both rod and URI or ice both of whom
would constantly beg him to eradicate
the pure Titans due to the VAR
announcing War he never once made an
attempt to do this which is something
his sons couldn't understand based on
his personal Library here he clearly
enjoyed reading but when what bothered
him too much he'd lock his son inside a
dungeon doesn't really seem like a
proportionate response but you know if
you're the king of the walls I guess you
can do what you want eventually the time
came for one of his sons to become the
next founder and Ernie was certain he'd
be able to do what his father couldn't
sadly though after inheriting this Titan
he was immediately consumed by
carthrit's VAR announcing war and never
spoke again about destroying the Titans
outside the walls in a flashback scene
we got a small look at the design of his
founding Titan although the form was
mostly incomplete on this day the two
Reich Brothers have been traveling
together but were ambushed by Kenny
Ackerman who was given their location by
a royal government official knowing they
had been betrayed by someone the King
was eager to find out who told Kenny
where they'd be but he couldn't use the
Founder's power to make him talk as an
Ackerman Kenny was immune from those
type of Mind Games which like I said is
part of the reason they were hunted down
and persecuted URI therefore understood
why someone from that clown would want
to kill him which is why even with a
knife in his arm it was the king who
apologized and bowed down following this
encounter the two of them actually
became friends with URI putting an end
to the ackerman's persecution at least
in a official capacity he then hired
Kenny to be a fixer for the rice family
and over the years it's implied that two
of them were quite candid with each
other with the King even telling him
that his power was going to be
transferred during his time as the
founding Titan URI frequently gave
sermons about peace to those within his
inner circle including the interior
police and of course Kenny as his 13
years came closer to an end the curse of
Emir really started to make him look
like an old man he had gray hair
wrinkles and a walking stick which means
his Titan regeneration must have also
been getting really slow with old age
one interesting thing about URI is that
he predicted the world would be
destroyed in the not too distant future
and at first I thought this statement
referred to the Warriors invading the
island given the context we have now
though it's likely to sayama wrote this
line with the rumbling on his mind
instead
moving on Frieda rice became the new
founding Titan in the year 842 and just
like urishi thought she could overcome
the will of Carl Fritz spoiler alert she
couldn't but let's explain who she is in
the first place by all accounts Frida
was one of the nicest characters in the
series and was the eldest daughter of
Rod rice whereas what completely ignored
the existence of his youngest child's
Historia it was Freedom that went out of
her way to teach the girl to read write
and write horses in many ways it was her
influence that made Historia The Humble
person she became and at the age of 15
Frida inherited the founding Titan
choosing to eat your uncle is never an
easy decision but she did it to save
Humanity from the Titans because like I
said she thought she could override the
VAR announcing war after gaining the
founders she would begin to give
speeches like her uncle used to do and
in her spare time she played with
Historia and then wipe her memory
afterwards she did this to protect her
younger half-sister since being of Royal
Blood does tend to put a Target on
someone's back Historia noted how
sometimes Frida would act like a totally
different person and these moments were
when the king's will was the strongest
the best example in my opinion is when
Grisha confront wanted her in the rice
Chapel because Frida's entire speech was
literally spoken as if it was called for
it himself in terms of her founding
Titan's design she didn't have the
exposed ribs or long arms of her
predecessors and her height was slightly
shorter than Chris's attack Titan as a
result of the bar announcing War she was
defeated pretty easily by Grisha even
though her shifter is in theory meant to
be unbeatable on a random note there was
that one occasion when Aaron witnessed a
memory of Frida brushing her hair and
the anime definitely made it seem like
she saw him looking at her whether she
actually did or not is Up For Debate
because as Grisha said she never really
had access to the founders for potential
given that leave our announcing War
civilian limits what she can do
following that fight the eighth founder
in this video is of course Grisha Jaeger
who is responsible for merging the
attack Titan and the founding Titan into
one body all things considered he had
this power for a really short time as he
stole it from Frida and then forcibly
made Aaron eat him not long after that
there was never really a scenario in
which Grisha could have actually used
the coordinate but rather his sole
purpose was to transfer the power from
the rice family to the Jaegers being in
Aldine restorationist he had wanted this
Titan taken from the royal family for a
long time but I'm sure he never imagined
it would be up to him given that he
wanted his wife to take it at first and
then he wanted his son to take it but no
he ended up being the one trusted to do
it to his credit he did locate the true
royal family after only a few years
which when you compare that to Molly's
four Warriors I mean first of all it's
way more impressive and I caught up the
thing they might have been more
successful if they sent experienced
adults like Grisha or people like that
rather than 12 year old kids anyway on
the first occasion he visited the rice
Chapel he chose not to confront the
Royals for the sake of his family but he
would eventually return on the day
Marley invaded as I explained in my
video about every attack Titan it was
Aaron from the future that motivated
Grisha to kill Freda in the first place
but that wouldn't have been possible
without the unknowing help of
Christian's first son Zeke is the next
person on this list to have used the
finest power and he was the first world
in over a century to have access to its
full potential while it is true that he
didn't have a physical founding Titan
body his use of its power is still an
essential part of the story that can't
be overlooked a while ago it was
established that if a Titan of real
blood makes contact with the founder
then that person can get around its
limitations we witnessed this first time
when Aaron commanded an army of pure
Titans after touching Dino Fritz despite
the fact he's a regular alien who
shouldn't be able to use the coordinate
the second time Aaron touched a royal
blooded Titan was when his decapitated
head fell into Zeke's hands but this
time there was a Twist unlike previous
Royals Zeke arrived here without being
tainted by the will of King Fritz
meaning he was free to command yumea
however he wanted after spending a long
time in his realm before Aaron arrived
he learned about the extent of emir's
abilities and how she's a slave to Royal
blooded individuals on a basic level
whoever Ymir listens to is the one that
controls the founder and she initially
listened to Zeke because he has royal
blood in his very brief time in charge
of the founder the LD Sega brother tried
to use this power for four main things
number one is that he created these
easily breakable chains around his body
as he wanted to pretend he was trapped
by the vow to renounce War this was part
of Zeke's test to see if Aaron was
really on his side and it was a test
that was very quickly failed number two
is that he made some actual change to
restrict Aaron and these ones were so
tough that Aaron had to rip his thumbs
off to Break Free the third and most
game-changing use of this power was when
he physically took his brother into
their father's memories since he was
trying to prove that Grisha had
brainwashed Aaron by doing this Zeke
unknowingly gave his brother the chance
to talk to the memory of their father
and then send that message back to the
real Grisha in the past the real Grisha
was able to see those memories due to
the Future memory inheritance of the
attack Titan but Zeke never knew this
could happen because he didn't know
about that ability in this way Aaron was
able to manipulate the past and make his
father kill Frida however it was only
possible because Zeke took Aaron into
that memory in the first place
the fourth way is he tried to use the
founder was more of a fail as he
commanded yamir to sterilize all aliens
across the globe this had been his plan
since he was a teenager yet it didn't
work out because Aaron spoke to the
founder as a person convincing Emir that
she should choose what happens next
rather than simply being a slave to the
Royal bloodline Zeke desperately tried
to convince her to still follow him but
by then she had already chosen Aaron's
side and the Founder's power awakened in
him soon afterwards it's crazy how all
those events happened in a split second
in reality but in the past Dimension it
was clearly a notable period of time in
any case the last founding Titan is
Aaron Jaeger who was a character that
needs no introduction with yamir on his
side he was able to unleash the full
power of the coordinator in what was the
biggest spectacle we've ever seen his
first action was to undo all-time
hardening in the world which included
not just the wars and parodies but also
the armatan's armor fell apart and
Annie's Crystal came undone as well he
then used the founding Titan in a way
we've never seen before since he
telepathically sent a message to every
alien on the planet Millions upon
millions of subjects were summoned to
the pause demand regardless of where
they were in the real world and Aaron
proceeded to tell them his intention to
end life outside the walls this
telepathic ability was then put to use
even further as Aaron later spent time
visiting each of his friends to say
goodbye during this goodbye tour he
showed Armin the amazing natural
landscapes that they spoke about when
they were kids and for Mikasa he made a
world in which they lived in a cabin in
the woods one thing that's so clear is
whether Aaron is able to just create
these environments literally out of
nothing or if he's simply showing them
memories from eldens of the past in a
similar way to how Zeke took them into
gracious memories regardless of the way
he does it it's possible these two could
have spent a longer time in pause than
what we saw in the Final Chapter given
that time pass is faster in there
compared to the real world speaking of
time Aaron noted how the founders powers
make him experience the past present and
future simultaneously this is why he's
unable to deviate from the end result
where he dies because it's all a fixed
timeline that can only have one outcome
this is where we get to one of his most
controversial uses of the founding Titan
which was Aaron influencing the past to
make sure the events of the first
episode happened this this reveal was
foreshadowed back in season 4 when the
dinosaurs Titan bizarrely walked
straight past Bertolt despite being a
pure Titan these paths transcend time
itself so he used this ability to
preserve the fixed timeline in his words
he had to do it since it wasn't better
time to die and the official translation
makes it clear that Aaron made Diner
then go in the direction of his home
this is of course so that she can go to
his house and eat his mother and in the
process put young Aaron on the path he
needs to go on
as I said in my review of the Final
Chapter it's not like future Aaron
wanted to do these things it's just that
he can't fight against a past and a
future that was already predetermined
when he kissed historia's hand that was
the first time he saw Dino Fritz's
memory of verto from her perspective and
initially it was confusing why Aaron was
seeing this but now we know why in terms
of the design of Aaron's fighting Titan
it was quite easily the largest Titan in
history making even the Colossal look
tiny by comparison its main body is
nearly identical in shape to the
hallucigenia and this is possibly due to
the way this shifter was created if we
go back when Aaron and Zeke touched each
other I mean Aaron was just ahead so
this worm needed to create a brand new
Titan body from scratch with the end
result being a bony creature similar to
its own design each of these bones act
like legs that slowly move forward and
at the very front of the body we have
Aaron himself in my opinion the overall
design of this Titan is literally a
metaphor for how he doesn't have any
free will hear me out here most of the
body is in the shape of this ancient
worm which itself represents the power
of the found founder it was this same
power that robbed Aaron of his freedom
since it gave him an inevitable fate
that he could never deviate from at the
front of the body Aaron presents himself
as the one being in charge but when we
look at his arms they're being held up
by something just like a puppet on his
string Aaron is being controlled by the
founding Titan and the way his arms are
hanging draw direct parallels with this
the string holding him up originates
from the hallucinogenia so it further
hits home that he is simply a puppet of
the founding Titan moving on the
coordinate's next ability was shown in
the final battle when it began
resurrecting shifters from the past
these ancient Titans were summoned by
Emir to defend Aaron and the story made
it clear they weren't just minus zombies
although most of them did do what yamir
wanted it really didn't take much
convincing for others to switch sides
and fight with the alliance Bertolt Sava
and Grisha and also many other
characters they all rallied behind those
who were trying to stop the rumbling
indicating that they did have some form
of Consciousness and were able to reject
what yamir wanted other powers include
being able to replicate the form of any
other Titan evidence when Aaron himself
made a brand new colossal body this
ability shouldn't be too surprising
given the way the coordinate was used to
make millions of Titans on a whim
however it is still strange seeing
Aaron's head on this particular Titan
towards the climax of Attack on Titan it
was also made very clear that if he
wanted to he could remove these shifter
abilities from the other eight Titans
ultimately he didn't do this since there
was no other way they even had a chance
of beating him but the option was always
there in the penultimate chapter the
hallucinogenia produced a gas that turns
aliens into pure Titans and this works
on any subject except for ackermans or
Titan Shifters it's safe for us to
assume the founders of the past could do
a similar thing as this is very likely
where Marley got inspiration from to try
it themselves final thing to mention
before we end the video is that the real
Aaron was located in the mouth of his
founding Titan and was connected to the
body via his spine and these weird
fleshy appendages after Mikasa killed
him the symbiotic ancient worm also
disappeared putting a seemingly
permanent entity power of the Titans as
always thank you guys guys for watching
this video on all founding Titans in
history and be sure to smash that sub
button if you want to see more stuff
like this I'd also appreciate if you hit
that like button as well as it does help
out the video and until the next one
peace out